welcome back everybody to the David
Pacman show Luke Beasley here filling in
for David while he is away let's Dive
Right In well the Tennessee house
Republican effort and successful
temporarily effort to expel two out of
three of the Tennessee three as they're
being called or the Democratic State
lawmakers who protested the inaction of
Republicans on the house floor
peacefully and because of their
violation of the decorum rules they were
expelled by Republicans in the state of
Tennessee the House of Representatives
specifically and this has backfired
epically not only raising even more
attention to the fact that Republicans
are unserious about actually solving the
issues
that face Americans or citizens in
Tennessee more specifically and of
course that applies to gun violence in
such a disastrous way and it's backfired
beyond that as well because now one of
the individuals that expelled Justin
Jones has been reinstated to his
position as a Tennessee state
representative and the way that this
works and then we'll dive into some
videos from this and some reporting on
it the Nashville metropolitan council is
the entity the legislative body
um
that is responsible whenever a situation
like this takes place a state
representative is expelled the Nashville
metropolitan Council for Representatives
that represent that area is responsible
for choosing who's going to be the
interim representative so here they're
choosing Justice Justin Jones to be the
interim for uh the seat he got expelled
from
um and then he'll hold that until an
election and if he chooses to run for it
I'm sure he'll be able to actually get
back in through that as well so a
complete failure in so many different
ways on the part of the Republican party
in Tennessee
take a look at this from CNN and then
we'll look at some videos from this
after being sworn back into the
Tennessee House of Representatives
Monday a lawmaker who was expelled just
days ago over a gun control
demonstration on the chamber floor says
he'll continue to call for gun reform
quote the first thing I do when I walk
into this building as a representative
is to continue that call for common
sense gun legislation Justin Jones said
Jones and another black Democrat Justin
Pearson were forced out of the
republican-controlled legislature last
week after a protest on the chamber
floor spurred by the mass shooting last
month at a Nashville Christian School
that left six people dead a third
Democrat who joined them in the protest
and in protest representative Gloria
Johnson avoided expulsion and then it
notes there the Nashville metropolitan
Council voted 36-0 Monday to reappoint
Jones to the House of Representatives
um
putting him back into his same
previously held position and I will show
you this swearing-in here let's talk a
little bit about Justin Jones the state
representative he has just he's just now
being sworn in only moments ago being
sworn in as the new state representative
after he was expelled a few days ago
because he was protesting in favor of
gun reform and they the Republicans in
the state legislature expelled him but
now he's being he was just voted by the
city council there to be reinstated in
Nashville and now he's just been sworn
in a very very dramatic development
indeed let's talk
and credit to
the uh Nashville city council
for doing this
um
absolutely correct decision there and
then I'll show you a little bit of his
remarks out in front of the Tennessee
Capitol
message that democracy will not be
killed in the comfort of Silence
hey we send a clear message to speaker
Cameron Sexton that the people will not
allow his his crimes against democracy
to happen without challenge
yeah the people of Nashville have spoken
today through their council members and
democracy we stand for the vision of a
multi-racial democracy democracy is our
is the vision we're offering to this
body this building that has forgotten it
and I've talked about this more
extensively on my show you can find that
at Luke Beasley on YouTube but just the
way that nothing represents more
accurately than what we're watching play
out in Nashville Tennessee
um the
incorrect nature of the ideology of much
of the Republican Party especially when
it comes to gun violence in the way that
we uh address gun violence and while
there are multiple fronts in which we
need to fight that battle make sure
we're uh implementing Solutions
that is a multi-faceted approach but you
can't honestly want to address
um the unique to America problem that we
have here with gun violence and ignore
the gun control element other things too
mental health too uh school safety two
all of that and gun control
and so the fact that the focus after
this mass shooting by Tennessee
Republicans was not to implement those
Common Sense Solutions but instead to
focus on expelling members who were
calling for those Common Sense Solutions
highlights the
broken nature of this ideology better
than much else for sure and then just to
round this out uh here is representative
Justin Jones walking back into the
chamber
[Applause]
[Music]
so there it is uh good for
the people of
Tennessee Justin Jones the Nashville
city council a shame on the Republicans
of course for causing this whole
situation
and we'll see how it continues to play
out
well before I get to a clip here from
MSNBC of democratic representative
Maxwell Frost talking about a proposal a
bill actually he's introduced to create
an office of gun violence prevention
and a great idea and all around we need
more action specifically by Republicans
for them to get on board with common
sense solutions to gun violence
decreasing the Carnage we experience in
America
before we get to that though we have
seen yet another devastating mass
shooting and this is what is being
responded to in the clip I'm about to
show you
um hear from the Lexington Herald Leader
a gunman opened fire in a downtown
Louisville Bank Monday morning killing
at least five people and hospitalizing
eight others the Louisville Metro Police
Department confirms few details have
emerged but by Monday afternoon about
the shooter or their victims but
emotional Governor uh Andy Bashar did
say one of the deceased as oh my gosh as
a very close friend during a news
conference while this is Kentucky's
first mass shooting of 2023 it's the 146
mass shooting in the U.S just this year
that's according to the gun violence
archive 146 mass shootings just this
year
in America
and as I said in the last segment on
today's show it is a multi-faceted
approach to decrease gun violence to
address this problem but you can't
ignore one of the primary components
which is the gun
that is how we are set
so far apart from other countries When
comparing developed countries their gun
violence the reality of guns and the
regulation and there's two ways that are
clear and present
and undeniable
um
two ways that we are very different from
other developed countries
the first is the amount and how
unregulated our guns are
and the second is how much gun balance
we have so you can connect the dots
there
and we don't have to be seeing this type
of
um
Devastation on such a regular basis here
is democratic representative Maxwell
Frost talking about his proposal for an
office of gun violence prevention
people were forward-thinking Progressive
candidates and thinking about ways of
how we're going to end gun violence at
every level of government I actually
just introduced my first bill which
creates a federal office of gun violence
prevention which will help do just that
work with Municipal Cities state
governments and Congress to provide
recommendations and give the data that
we need to solve this problem
holistically but what we will refuse is
politicians who go in front of cameras
and say oh it's going to happen anyway
there's nothing we can do if that is
what you if that's the energy you're
bringing to this problem you don't
belong in the seat of power you don't
belong in a place where you represent
the people because every death is a
policy failure
yeah
so while it would absolutely be
something I'd support to set up an
office of gun violence prevention it
also should be noted
while there is
absolutely complexity to how we go about
solving this in another way it's simple
in terms of what the next step has to be
and the only way reasonably
realistically we're going to address and
decrease gun violence in the United
States is for the Republican party to
change their stance on this that's just
the reality and so down the road there
are so many fascinating complex
conversations about how we go about
generally addressing crime and gun
violence Massachusetts all that
but the next step has to be we Implement
Common Sense gun regulation and What's
blocking that the Republican party next
moment uh from this interview
I think we're going to continue to see
that this youth litter come out will
continue to rise we've seen the past
three Cycles have had wildly amazing
youth Hood turnout numbers and we're not
done yet you know in 2020 we had the
highest Jupiter turnout in the history
of our country and half of gen Z can't
even vote yet meanwhile the Republican
party is focused on changing the voters
and you know there's something wrong
with your policy party when your path to
Victory is changing the voters and
gerrymandering our maps to hell and
that's what's going on right now it's
anti-democratic it's not democracy and
it's not the freedom and liberty that
the party tends to hold up the
Republican Party holds up as their
Banner true patriotism is loving the
people in the country it's not just
about the flag it's about the people in
the country and it's something that this
generation gen Z and young folks
understand and that's why we're going to
continue to fight we will vote but we
also will hit the streets and we also
will take care of one another and I I
think that holistic interpretation of
what a movement is is part of the reason
why in Young Folks are going to really
build political power quickly in this
country it's using every single tool in
our toolbox
so uh I really do like that line of true
patriotism is loving the people in the
country it's not just about the flag
it's about the people in the country and
I think that highlights
what we'll see
um from
many within the Republican Party
this
uh
this insistence on focusing on things
that are much more symbolic than they
are
actually impacting people in their
day-to-day life and that is why in large
part they distract with a lot of these
what are referred to as culture War
issues things that are
uh vague enough abstract enough and
symbolic enough where you can get people
riled up about it but not actually be
held to any standard it's not a tangible
promise that you can be held to and his
example of
true patriotism being about the people
and not about the flag it's great to
have the flag as a representation of our
country and all that but when patriotism
to you is just symbolic it's just
wearing the flag it's just
um
whatever it might be your
the way you go about uh saying the
Pledge of Allegiance and the hand over
heart and all of that and all of it can
be great and wonderful
but let that let's make sure that's not
a replacement for what is actual
patriotism
which is fighting for the Improvement of
the lives of people within the country
and David has recently talked about
someone I think wrote Into the show or
called in the show
um and talked about how Republicans are
able to kind of co-opt these terms these
positive terms patriotism and it is
theirs or even the flag an American flag
being a republican thing often which is
strange
um it's all of our flag but
it it definitely happens The Branding
the messaging within the Republican
Party often is more effective if even if
dishonest
um and I think
those on the left need to work harder to
make sure we don't just allow the
conversations to always be on their Turf
because no I don't think it's patriotic
to spend all your time focusing on your
obsession with
you know your guns and and flag shirt
instead of focusing on protecting
children in schools based on common
sense Solutions
um and I don't think it's patriotic to
allow
so many people to be in poverty in this
country and
not getting enough in the proper food
and we could list off the racial
inequality that we have the rolling back
of rights for women that we're seeing
and on and on it goes that's not
patriotic to me if you really love your
country
you would love the people in it and if
you really loved your country and the
people in it then you would want to
solve problems facing those people
seems pretty clear to me but obviously a
lot of people don't buy into that and
it's all about the songs and the flags
instead of
the people much more after this
don't forget that the best way to
support the David Pacman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the Daily bonus show The Regular Show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire Archive of every episode
dating back a really long time and
plenty of other awesome membership perks
go to joinpakman.com joinpakman.com
right-wing media figure and founder of
Turning Point USA Charlie Kirk has I
guess you would say been more
transparent on his stance
on gun violence than other right-wingers
are willing to be clarified
what he thinks we should
and more importantly shouldn't it be
more importantly to him shouldn't be
doing when it comes to gun violence
addressing gun violence with common
sense Solutions and as you're about to
watch he thinks the devastation we
experience in this country unique to
this country When comparing us to other
developed Nations is worth it he thinks
it's worth it because of his distorted
view of this whole conversation take a
look now we must also be real we must be
honest with the population
having an armed citizenry comes with a
price
and that that is part of Liberty
driving comes to the price fifty
thousand fifty thousand fifty thousand
people die on the road every year
wow that's a price you get rid of
driving you'd have 50 000 Less Auto
fatalities but we have decided that the
benefit of driving speed accessibility
Mobility having products Services is
worth
the cost of 50 000 people dying on the
road so we need to be very clear that
you're not going to get gun deaths to
zero it will not happen right you can
significantly reduce them they're having
more fathers in the home by having more
we'll watch more of this clip but to
respond to what he's already said if you
want to make guns like cars I'm down to
do that that's what I want to do the
same
as extensive if not more process to
license someone make sure that they have
the proper training understanding
um and mental stability to have
a weapon
um that can do so much damage and they
do this often what cars kill a lot of
people or people a lot of people die in
car wrecks are you saying banned cars no
they're heavily regulated for that
reason we've seen deaths
uh
by car
decreased significantly as we've
increased significantly regulation so
yes let's do it but Charlie Kirk's not
for that
so don't be bringing up cars like that
some point because that's exactly what
people on the side of Common Sense gun
control are calling for implementing
systems to make sure people can't just
willy-nilly get so many guns and
um
people who shouldn't have guns can get
them and all of that
continuing armed guards in front of
schools
we should have a honest and clear
reductionist view of gun violence oh and
that point Who's saying we're gonna get
completely rid of gun violence
that's such a strong man uh argument
people think we're we can't so that
means we have to do nothing we can't get
rid of gun violence so we have to do
nothing according to Charlie Kirk but
not have a utopian one you will never
live in a society when you have an armed
citizenry and you won't have a single
gun death that is nonsense it's dribble
but I am I I think it's I think it's
worth it
I think it's worth to have a cost of
unfortunately some gun deaths every
single year so that we can have the
Second Amendment to protect our other
god-given rights that is a prudent deal
it is rational
nobody talks like this they live in a
complete alternate universe so then how
do you reduce very simple people say oh
Charlie how do you stop school shootings
I don't know how did we stop shootings
at baseball games
because we have armed guards outside of
baseball games that's why
how do we stop all the shootings at
airports
we have armed guards outside of airports
how do we stop all the shootings at
Banks we have armed guards outside of
banks there was just a shooting at a
bank so
and
people are fully willing
to have Security on the campus of
schools now getting to the point when I
hear some right-wingers talk about their
Ideal school situation where it feels
like a prison is terrifying to go
I'm not on board with that but having an
armed security guard on campus perfectly
fine and also that armed security guard
unless you have an army is not going to
be able to fend off someone
in many cases walking up with a weapon
of War
we saw in Uvalde a team of police
officers countless officers and they
weren't
willing to enter the room as they should
have because of the weapon they were
saying there's an AR-15 there's an AR-15
that the shooter had so yes let's have
security let's have locked doors
let's also not make the environment one
this terrifying to go to and as other
countries do let's
reasonably regulate firearms
how do we stop all the shootings at gun
shows notice there's not a lot of mass
shootings at gun shows there's all these
guns
because everyone's armed
oh my goodness
it's the laughing at the point of
quote worth it that's the words that
Charlie Kirk has for
dead kids worth it because he thinks
that
we need weapons of war because maybe
he'll be able to have some Rambo moment
against the government it's not going to
happen if in some situation
very hypothetically
we were you know experiencing a
tyrannical government where we're going
to have to go to war with them
they if the military is on the side of
that tyrannical government they win it's
over they have the military drones they
have the missiles they have all the
different things we're not gonna
when with even your AR-15 and so to
choose that because you like the idea of
this hypothetical where you're some
action figure
over the lives of children to me is sick
and
he is now out and out saying we've seen
a shift
recently and he's joining along with
that shift within the right wing spaces
the pro
um I shouldn't say even pro gun you can
be pro-gun and also Pro reason and want
to reasonably regulate guns not revoking
your second amendment but just
reasonably regulating us
um
and we've seen this shift and you kept
thinking or at least I did that
eventually there would be a shift within
the Republican ideology because it would
just get too bad and they would go okay
we need to we need to change our view
and just go ahead and regulate the guns
yes focus on these other areas and the
guns
but we got the shift just not in the
direction I thought we were gonna get it
and now you have uh Republican
representative burchett
saying ah you know criminals are going
to be criminals there's nothing we can
do about it talking about Congress
saying
um there's nothing we're going to be
able to do to address gun violence then
Charlie Kirk there and countless others
just saying yeah no no we're not even
gonna do the whole we care but we just
think
we need to figure out other ways to
address gun violence he's just saying
yeah maybe I'll do a little vague
gesture towards armed guards but we've
seen that and uh we've seen how as I
said a weapon of War can make that fact
irrelevant
and uh so then at the end of the day his
response is yeah it's worth it Charlie
Kerr he's down with it and as I said to
me that's sick and I don't want to hear
one more time
from anyone who holds that position that
they get to demonize lgbtq people in the
name of protecting the kids
or obsess over people
expressing themselves doing drag
performance because they care about the
kids no you don't no you don't not one
single bit if it's worth it to you to
watch them die
well what we saw in New York with the
indictment of trump in regard to the
Stormy Daniels hush money uh payment
maybe just the beginning likely is just
the beginning of his legal troubles as
I'm sure you're aware and it could get
much worse very soon for him before we
dive into some reporting on this
something I've been talking about a good
bit on my show you can find that at Luke
Beasley on YouTube is while Trump should
be held accountable wherever he is
violated the law including the Stormy
Daniels case it's unfortunate that the
Stormy Daniels cases being the less
significant one came first when we have
as we're about to talk about
a case where he could be held
accountable for attempting to overturn a
free and fair election pressuring
election officials the Brad
raffensberger call all those things and
that being one of the cases he's
involved in
one of the things he's being
investigated for makes the Stormy
Daniels case seem less significant
and so the fact that it came first is
unfortunate but we could be seeing the
more important one significant with huge
ramifications also coming very soon take
a look at this from The Washington Post
Donald Trump's appearance in a Manhattan
courtroom Tuesday marked a singular
moment in American history the first
time a former or sitting U.S president
has been indicted on criminal charges
but Trump's legal Peril is far from over
among those closely watching the
proceedings were state and local
officials in Georgia where Fulton County
district attorney Fanny T Willis is
expected to announce in coming weeks
whether she will file charges in
connection to efforts by Trump and his
allies to overturn the states 2020
presidential election results it
expected to announce in the coming weeks
and we saw the media tour that the grand
jury uh four-person did
that was strange but it did reveal at
least in the eyes of the grand jury
likely charges indictments were
recommended and
if Fannie Willis follows in that path we
could be seeing charges very soon in
regard to what I see as the most
important thing Trump is being
investigated for if you somehow have
forgotten what this is all in reference
to or one of the elements of this
investigation here was the infamous
Georgia call or at least a part of it so
is this I just want to find
uh 11 780
votes so tell me Brad what are we going
to do we won the election and it's not
fair to take it away from us like this
and it's going to be very costly in many
ways and
I think you have to say that you're
going to re-examine it we have to stand
by our numbers we believe our numbers
are right Georgia has now
all I want to do is find eleven thousand
seven hundred and eighty votes I've
heard that so many times now
um but I
every single time I hear it
I
cannot process that that actually
happened and all that was surrounding
that wasn't just him calling trying to
get Brad raffensberger to throw out the
election results and find 11 780 votes
that didn't exist and Proclaim him the
winner it was also him coming up with
this alternate elector scheme having a
vice president at the time Mike Pence
reject the actual electors pretend fake
electors were the real ones and and
stall Trump the president throw us into
a constitutional crisis a coup
a a non-military coup was being
attempted there luckily it didn't work
but he absolutely needs to be held
accountable and then a little bit here
from Yahoo news while Tuesday's
arraignment of foreign president Donald
Trump marked the first time a former U.S
president has had ever been charged with
criminal offenses it likely won't be the
last by summers in Trump could be
charged and no fewer than four separate
criminal investigations oh goodness
in fact while Trump's indictment
stemming from his 130 000 hush money
payment a thousand dollar hush money
payment to adult film star Stormy
Daniels represents a legal threat to the
former president The Others May carry a
greater risk of serious consequences
including a possible prison sentence as
most people recognize it's hard to
picture Trump being sent to prison
especially for these Stormy Daniels
case
but if we're going to see that happen or
at least him get house arrest
um
then I do think it'll come from one of
the other cases and of course you have
the federal investigation to his
mishandling and obstruction and regards
the documents classified documents you
have the federal investigation to
January 6 as attempts to overtime the
election you have the Georgia
investigation to his attempts to
overturn the election and then you have
the Manhattan district attorneys uh
investigation of the Stormy Daniels hush
money payment so a lot going on there uh
for Trump we have much more on the other
side of this break
if you value what we do at the David
packman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com davidpackman
show where you can get access to behind
the scenes videos The Daily bonus show
the commercial free Daily Show as well
as special discounts on merch including
hats hoodies mugs and t-shirts you can
support the show for as little as two
dollars a month check it out at
patreon.com davidpackman show Fox News
is in somewhat of a panic in the wake of
the Wisconsin Supreme Court election
results that once again highlighted the
strength and passion uh behind abortion
rights democracy and other crucial
issues and how the Republican stance on
those
things the actions they've been taking
is just not popular especially as
um will be talked about here the younger
Generations get more active in politics
and there's different approaches I'll
show you a couple here some just
recognizing how these issues directly
have impacted election results and
um I've seen kind of here and there
calls for Republicans to moderate
themselves otherwise they're going to
keep losing but some do what I'm about
to show you here with kellyanne Conway
what she's doing which is come up with a
rather incoherent and cope copy way to
deal with the fact that
the modern conservative ideology just
isn't popular with the majority of
Americans and that's why we saw the
underwhelming midterm results that's why
we saw and especially because the
Republican party is being driven by this
Maga ideology and the radical stances on
things like abortion rights
um that's why we've seen when abortion
rights
are on the ballot or when they're
directly tied to a candidate
abortion rights Prevail
um as I said the Wisconsin election
results and others and this is how
kellyanne Conway uh synthesized this
reality so we can't be beaten on this
policy wise I think we've already won
the policy arguments on the economy on
education on a number of issues I think
we've got some work to do on the young
people who think um differently on
abortion perhaps or guns or climate
change but even there the Democrats
messages are usually cynical the place
I'm really con the thing I'm really
concerned about so cynical let's protect
women's rights with this Laura is that
the left becomes a turnout machine with
young people because influencers have
this domino effect lemming-like effect
of people just all them wanting to be
part of the same crowd and if they
succeed in that way we're not doing a
great job competing for ballots we're
just competing for votes our candidates
lost the early voting
miserably last time I mean someone like
Dr Oz lost the early vote to John
Federman by over four to one so we need
to compete for ballots not just voters
and not just minds and I think they're
trying to do that with these influencers
I have faith in the American people I
think I'll catch on to this and say I
want a policy argument
well kellyanne I think you raised an
excellent point though and and it seems
like the Republicans are always playing
catch-up even though it's obvious what
happened last time with the early voting
and you know all these folks who run the
RNC and other you know other I guess
Republican Outlets that are supposed to
be getting this right this time what are
they doing are they you know getting
their own ballot harvesting operation
going where it's legal are they you know
lining up their own channels for early
voting is that going to happen this time
do you have confidence in that
so they're trying to make this absurd
distinction between uh and we'll get to
another clip here from Fox but
between
ballots and votes and they're saying
Democrats go and they harvest ballots
and they win through the ballot game and
we were just focusing on votes and
nuanced policy discussions
um I haven't seen policy coming
significant nuanced uh meaningful policy
conversations coming from Republicans at
least the driving Corps of the
Republican Party being Maga in a very
long time maybe ever when it comes to
that particular movement but
there's this perception that the
increased votes or the success in
different elections
and this is slightly different than this
it's different than the stolen election
conspiracy theory but it kind of is a
child of that where there's something
malicious a mysterious going on with the
Democratic party and that's why more
young voters are supporting them or
that's why they were successful in these
states
um in this election or that election or
that's why abortion rights are impacting
elections so significantly that's why
people care about democracy all that and
it's just not true it's not a balance
for us both balance are the ways the way
that we vote and uh more people just
vote in favor of some of these
Democratic policies in a lot of
situations especially younger voters but
even they try to craft this narrative
um
that
it's just the Gen Z that Republicans are
unpopular with which they are very
unpopular with Gen Z but the radical
stances on abortion gun control
democracy with the attempts to overturn
the election results
um and others are unpopular with the
majority of
just America generally and still gen Z
is a very small portion of the voting
population so it's mostly not gen Z and
still you're very unpopular
um and find ways to eke out victories of
course and still have a lot of power but
generally the ideology is just not
something people can get behind and it's
not going to consistently be supported
especially as
I said the younger Generations get more
involved in politics and so for
kellyanne Conway it's let's ballot
Harvest you can only be successful in
ballot harvesting which is just getting
a third party to take someone's ballot
to the polling place so if it's an
elderly person they can
have a family member or something take
that ballot to the polling place for
them
um but it's only successful if you
actually have people to fill out the
ballot who are real voters who actually
want to support the Republican party and
that's your issue
for sure next moment here responding to
these results check that out Brett you
followed these results in Wisconsin
um
interesting here's what we found for the
Gen Z vote into 2020 midterms they won
77-21 for Democrats and now there's this
you know this it's not a five alarm fire
but it's concerned among Republicans as
to how they get young people to vote for
them especially with the issue of
abortion uh more or less on the ballots
in so many different state races uh this
is what kellyanne Conway told us just
last hour here and there's more
kellyanne Conway but I have an idea it's
gonna be it's gonna sound a little goofy
a little strange
and I'm not normally giving strategic
advice to Republicans but I'm going to
do it here you can take it to leave it
my wild idea
for not alienating certain voting
populations on the issue of abortion
is to have a less radical view on
abortion that would be my advice to the
Republican Party
um but definitely interesting to see
different ways in which he's being more
authentic and recognizing just the
Republicans have a stance that isn't
popular among so many populations while
Kelly and Conway saying it's a ballot
versus votes game
and um we will continue to watch it all
move forward make sure you're subscribed
to me on YouTube at Luke Beasley
Ron DeSantis has put himself in somewhat
of a pickle a conundrum a difficult
situation and I want to talk about that
now uh he because he got prominent being
the culture War guy the woke woke woke
CRT guy anti-walk woke I should say CRT
guy
um
Florida is where wealth goes to die you
know who I'm talking about that Rhonda
said this he became a big conversation
item for running for president possibly
challenging uh Trump in the 2024
presidential primary and he leaned into
and he's made clear with all of his
actions his tour and all that that it's
something he's planning on doing
but now it's seeming like not a great
idea and I want to show you before we
discuss further Sarah Longwell on MSNBC
talking about how he kind of now is
forced to go ahead and just run
but
and we'll discuss this more a second
it's not really a it's not a good time
for him to run but he kind of has to
which is fascinating what do you think
the chances are does Santa decides not
to run
oh I don't think he can decide at this
point not to run he's effectively
already in the race this really uh is
his moment yes he's a young guy but if
he you know he's positioned himself
really as a fighter and if he bows out
of this particular fight he will never
get that reputation back and the fact is
right now there is a big chunk of the
party you know I do focus groups every
week with Trump voters there's a big
chunk of the party that is DeSantis
curious and that wants to move on from
Donald Trump but Rob DeSantis is going
to have to figure out you know who he's
playing to in this primary he's sort of
decided for some reason that he's trying
to out Trump trump with the base and I
think that's a mistake I think he should
be trying to consolidate
um these sort of move on from Trump
voters and trying to to Really you know
uh yeah build relationships with them
and build a broad enough Coalition uh
that he can start getting these numbers
back and he can't do this thing where he
decides to be sort of a supporting
player in the drama around Donald
Trump's indictment uh where he's now out
there defending Trump he's going to have
to figure out a different strategy than
that if he wants to be effective
yes so what makes it hard for him to not
run now is number one is she noted if
he's branding himself as his fighter and
uh all of that but then he gets scared
Away by Trump and it was obviously it
was obvious he was gonna run but then he
decides not to and it's clear why that
doesn't look great but more importantly
he's already taking the political
attacks and the damage from Trump
because Trump identifies him as a
challenger and an enemy and so he's
getting the negatives of being attacked
by Trump but not the possible benefit of
being successful in a primary but then
if he does end up running now that the
indictment has happened and as she was
talking about
he is being a supportive character in
his story and his indictment and all of
that
there's no way a kind of I'm sort of the
Trump without baggage and I can out
Trump on vaccines maybe I could be more
anti-vaxx than him and more anti-woke
than him
but also I'm supportive of his dishonest
narratives and all these just different
areas including the indictment
um that's not going to work when Trump's
one of the candidates being a trump 2.0
when Trump's one of the candidates and
they can just pick the original
is definitely not a successful
strategy now would it work for anyone to
try to consolidate the non-trump vote I
don't know is there enough anti-trump
vote within the Republican party to even
make that possible or enough anti-plus
people who like Trump but want to move
on from him because a younger generation
or someone without baggage
I don't think so I think the majority of
the GOP is still on Trump's side but
that probably would be a better strategy
than just hey I'm like him but a little
better a little younger and
a little less baggage
um and
the attacks keep coming from Trump here
on true social Rhonda Santos is a young
man who is not doing well against me in
the polls that is true uh Sans is doing
much worse these days to put it mildly I
believe that if he decides to run for
president which will only hurt and
somewhat divide the Republican Party he
will lose the cherished and massive
macro vote and never be able to
successfully run for office again if he
remains Governor which is what Florida
voters assumed it would be a whole
different story just saying but who
knows he has such different moods on
true socialist either ah Rado Sanchez is
the worst and maybe he was a groomer
look at this photo or just a thought you
know maybe he shouldn't run but you do
you
but the uh Trump versus DeSantis Saga is
one I've been definitely enjoying
watching and we will continue to watch
it
follow us on social media interact with
the David packman show Community see
exclusive content See when we're taking
calls live and stay up to date on other
Big Show announcements WE Post daily
find us on Reddit Twitter Instagram
Facebook Discord and tick tock
governor of California Gavin Newsom did
an interview on MSNBC with Jin Saki and
I want to take a look at two moments
from this
the first he just very accurately uh
diagnosis and raises alarm about the
moment that we're in in this country
where rights are being rolled back and
people are being targeted in some
terrifying ways take a look at this and
then we'll discuss
also don't get what's going on in this
country I don't get why everybody's not
doing what we're doing I don't
understand it do people understand it's
not just about Mar-A-Lago it's not just
about what's happening in Washington DC
or what's happening in New York Court
with a district attorney there's
something deep and serious that's
happening across this country all the
progress the last half centuries being
rolled back in these states in real time
in just the last few years I don't think
people fully understand the rights
regression individual liberties on civil
rights on voting rights and the
gerrymandering that's happening out here
on just the assault on the
African-American Community The Assault
on the gay lesbian bisexual and trans
Community the number one issue of the
day it seems to be getting rid of the
word latinx in Arkansas and number two
getting rid of drag shows it's a serious
moment in American history and yet we're
so consumed respectfully by the
spectacles
in Washington that I as an American feel
compelled as a governor to call that out
and expose some of that in a more
systemic way and forgive me for being
intense about this but everything I have
taken for granted in my life in the last
half century in terms of Rights
expansion not even bring up abortion and
contraception all of that all of that is
in Peril at this moment and my kids they
need if I care about my kids I sure as
I'll better care about what's going on
in Alabama what's going on in
Mississippi in Arkansas and you know
what I'm coming back a much better
Governor because I spent a long weekend
with my kids here I do you took a trip
to Arkansas but uh it's absolutely right
because of the
almost reality TV nature
while drama
um that is American politics right now
it can be easy to get distracted from
some of the significant ways in which
damaging actions are being taken by the
Republican party and buy this modern
right wing that is driving the
Republican party and I think Gavin
Newsom better than a lot of those within
the uh within the Democratic party is
able to
call attention to that in
uh a tone that matches the moment I
think we see a lot of Democrats
um who maybe they realize the moment
that we're in and maybe they try to call
attention to it but it just doesn't
match in tone in rhetoric the way
uh that it should the moment that we're
in and that's what Gavin Newsom does
very effectively because it's scary
abortion rights
being targeted even though clearly
America is not on board with that with
the way that we are voting
as he noted the lgbtq community the
refusal to address problems such as gun
violence and racial inequality and
income inequality and on it goes it just
is so enraging that that's what we're
dealing with what it is and we can't let
the Mar-A-Lago debacles those are
important too and Trump's legal troubles
distract from the significant things
that also have to be focused on next
moment from this interview here it
sickens me in my court I'll tell you and
you would have more insight than anybody
so you can validate
um what happened in Tennessee triggered
this trip
just triggered I I can't I called the
White House full disclosure
um I said I can't take it I can't I got
four yet I can't I was given speeches
the same speech you've seen every
politician give Monterey Park down in
Salinas I gave it prior down in Gilroy
and when I was mayor
we see the dance
I mean I can't I just can't take it I
can't take it and then to see the same
Governors these were talk about mental
health you know unique apparently in
America to talk about you know our
parents and our family I mean all the BS
and then they claim to care about life
when the number one cause of death for
our children is guns shameful they're
shameful
and it should shock our souls but it's
becoming so normalized it's a matter of
hours now not even days
I mean I thought we would never move on
from Parkland or never move on from
Uvalde never move on from Buffalo I had
to read the manifesto I read the
manifesto from the shooter in Buffalo I
still have chills thinking about that
Manifesto to understand this this is
serious the manifesto allegedly for the
shooter in Tennessee all connected this
broader contagion they don't care about
our kids because if they did they'd ban
these damn weapons of war they would
have background checks they require some
common damn sense they don't so you know
what those kids they were there in the
capital God bless every single one of
them
we've talked a good bit about this
subject on today's show but I just don't
know how else to say it it's so true
what he's saying that
if you're gonna say you're the party of
protecting the kids as the GOP has been
saying
and then turn around and side with your
distorted this distorted and inaccurate
and correct view of what the Second
Amendment means that it means you can't
regulate at all
uh firearms
over the lives of
children and people of all ages but
because they say they want to protect
the kids
you're not being honest you don't
that's not an authentic motivation for
the things that you're doing it feels
nice to say
whenever
it comes time for
you to demonize lgbtq people
but no it's not authentic ambition to
protect the kids because you would start
if you cared about that you would start
with the leading cause of death for
children no doubt and so to choose again
the incorrect
interpretation that has been created of
the Second Amendment over the lives of
our children Highlights better than
anything else more accurately than
anything else
the dishonesty of that whole narrative
and it's sickening to watch
day after day we just got news of
another mass shooting in Louisville
five people dead
and
they're at schools but they're also all
over the place at a bank
um
and
there are lives being lost and also the
terror that is injected into just the
lives of people when they know this
could happen anywhere at any time
and all of that is not necessary
it really is not necessary nothing
makes that more clear than the fact that
we're the only country that experiences
when we compare ourselves to other
developed countries
this type of gun violence these numbers
in terms of mass shootings
and to think that's just a coincidence
and the reason why other countries don't
see this gun violence is just because
they don't have problems with mental
health for some magical reason no
it is clear what needs to be done and
it's not being done it's being blocked
from being done by so many within the
Republican Party failed gubernatorial
candidate Carrie Lake and uh Bonkers
election denier is clearly planning to
run for Senate or it's very likely that
she's going to run for Senate in Arizona
I have a moment from a recent interview
for you here where she gets asked about
her 2024 plans and
we've seen her showing up in Iowa so
some people are thinking is she wanting
to be Trump's vice presidential running
mate which I'm sure she would
want that as well but it does seem her
eyes are set on a senate run
um take a look
at this
puffball question wow you thought it was
going to be easy I thought it was okay
we're friends well then I'll just be
really honest which one do you want to
tackle the senate or the VP one first
let's hit them both head on okay um
obviously my case is is the most
important thing of course but you're
asking if things don't go well if the
judicial system is much more corrupt
than we than we think it is
what happens I am seriously considering
a run for Senate yes absolutely because
just because they sold an election we're
so dangerous to them I'm so dangerous to
the status quo and this rotten swamp
that they're willing to steal the
election to stop me and our movement I'm
not letting them get away with that
we're not going away and so you're
dangerous to democracy uh not dangerous
to the status quo and kind of a good way
of mixing things up and improving it
we'll watch a little bit more from this
but uh there
when politicians say I'm seriously
considering it that means it's
definitely happening because normally
the answer is oh I don't know I'm I'm
focused on only this I'm not even
thinking about that and still they like
clear considering if you say I'm really
seriously considering it that's
definitely uh the plan that you're
working on and again she's also
uh been seemingly auditioning to be
Trump's vice presidential running mate
so maybe she's waiting to see how that's
gonna work out but the bad part about
this
um and we'll talk about another
important angle on this after the second
clip I'm going to show you but uh first
is because Christian Cinema seems to
also be running for reelection as an
independent but is still left of center
and Ruben Gallegos in the race if Carrie
Lake does get into the race or another
Republican but especially someone as
dangerous as Carrie Lake just with her
election and dying and conspiracy
theories and all that
she'll have a better shot because of the
independent Democratic split situation
in my mind and how that could mix things
up
um so it'll definitely be something we
watch closely But continuing with this
interview
I am seriously considering a run for
Senate all the polling shows that I
would win not just the primary the
polling is showing I would beat both
Kirsten Cinema and this socialist guy
that's running their Democrats yeah and
so what are you worried though Kerry
because we know and it depends on the
poll that you look at Ruben Gallego has
been leading both Carey Lake and
Christian Cinema in polling recently the
voter rolls are corrupt we know that
these mail-in ballots can be corrupted
all these issues with Maricopa County
specifically and obviously if you run
for that senate seat just like
gubernatorial that's the entire State
not like a congressional district of
only 700 000 folks you're running for
the whole state how do we guarantee do
we have new stuff in place will you have
new poll Watchers make sure it's not
screwed this is why I'm fighting it
right now I want to I want to get our
elections straightened out and I want
them to be honest and that's why I'm
fighting it so hard right now we'll take
it to the Supreme Court if we okay and
then she's talking about her election to
but that is representative of this
strange logical
uh you know the the gymnastics that has
to be done mentally for supporters of
people like Trump and Kerry Lake because
now uh Trump is and Kerry Lake May soon
be running another campaign
and convincing their followers that yeah
as I keep saying the last election was
stolen
and nothing significantly has changed
within my conspiracy theory about what
is going on all the corruption
but I could win this one in the case of
trump the Dominion voting system with
flipping thousands and thousands of
votes from Trump to Biden but that's not
going to happen in 2024.
I don't understand as a follower how you
don't
just disengage and not understand uh how
your vote is going to make a difference
if the Democrats have this big
conspiracy where they can steal
elections as uh Carey Lake says in Trump
says
but the other
um
notable part about a possible 2024 uh
Carey Lake Senate run is how the
election denying will play into that
because
um for the General Electric obviously I
just talked about how it plays into her
own voters thinking it was stolen but
also thinking she could win it this one
but then how it plays into uh her
ability to win the general
election because we saw that not work
in 2022 now as I said with the unique
landscape with the independent that can
mix things up
but generally the midterms definitely
highlighted this
um
the American electorate wholesale is not
on board with uh the election tonight
and so for her to lean into that so much
and for her 2024 campaign to be similar
to trumps which is hey I lost that last
election but I don't think that I did is
a strange strategy and it really is as
you can tell in every interview she does
and all of her uh public statements it's
what she's obsessed with she can't
accept that she just lost so she has to
have like Trump the conspiracy theories
and so when that's a part of a campaign
I I just don't see how that works it
could unfortunately but reasonably I
don't see how that could work to say I
should be elected because I falsely
believe I lost the last or I actually
won the last time when I lost
um but that's the moment that we're in
in American politics make sure uh you
are subscribed to the Dave Pac-Man Show
YouTube channel and my YouTube channel
at Luke Beasley on YouTube so great uh
guest hosting today much love to you all
I'll see you soon
foreign